okay thanks for uh
i want to thank the organizers for for
inviting me and putting this conference
together it's been it's been a lot of
fun
and actually you know i i might talk
about quantum optimization and convex
information
if i get confused enough during this
talk so
you never know what i okay so what will
i tell you about um
i i normally hate outlines but i'm i'm
jumping around so much i think it would
be helpful
i will begin by doing a bit of a review
or introduction to the to quantum
information
i'll try and do it from maybe using the
language that would be natural
to people coming from an optimization
perspective
so i'll try and express kind of the main
ideas of quantum information
in a way that hopefully will be useful
and i'm going to talk
then generally about some of the
optimization problems that come up in
quantum mechanics
kind of not necessarily the ones that
i'm doing but sort of the big ones in
the field
and then i'll talk about how sdps can be
used for these
and then uh how we can analyze these
lps or sdps using ideas from
uh information theory or from quantum
information theory um
and this is sort of a coherent picture
altogether which says
that quantum mechanics gives us a new
way of understanding tensors
and it gives us new metaphors and new
language and some of that
includes ideas of quantum information
theory and so we can use
ideas like conditional mutual
information uh
that are kind of have much more
explanatory power
than just sort of directly using linear
algebra
and so i think that's a nice picture of
using uh sophisticated ideas from
quantum information theory to analyze
these hierarchies
and then at the end i'm going to
undermine my message a little bit by
giving you
very simple algorithms based on epsilon
nets that achieve the same performance
in some of these
and this is uh very recent results that
kind of haven't fully digested and i'm
hoping maybe people at the conference
can
can help me digest um okay so
so let me start off by just giving you a
brief summary of of some of the axioms
of quantum information
you can think of it as a a
non-commutative
generalization of of probability theory
this is my non-commutative picture
uh and uh
so great so so what does that look like
um so in probability theory
uh the states of the theory are are
vectors that are
have one norm equal to one and there are
non-negative real numbers
called delta n the the simplex of these
the probability simplex
um and what can we do with these states
one thing we can do
is we can apply decision rules to them
so a decision rule might look like you
get in a sample that's some number one
through n
and then for each possible value of that
you
decide either yes or no again with some
further probability so if it's
maybe you'll accept three always and
you'll accept four
uh one tenth of the time and you'll
accept five never
uh and these numbers are just a bunch of
numbers between zero and one
and you can call it a measurement so if
you get a sample a measurement to
something that turns that into a yes no
answer with some probability
so that the chance of accepting of
saying yes is just the inner product
between these vectors
and so you can also think of it as the
the polar so this is the l1 ball or the
positive part of it this is the l
infinity ball or the positive part of it
uh and this is uh
so they naturally like to take inner
products together
and the l1 norm is sort of the natural
ones used for states
for example if you want to distinguish
two states
with the best possible distinguishing
measurement then
the best bias possible is uh one half of
the
uh of the l one norm difference between
these two states
okay so those are the the axioms of
probability theory
uh quantum mechanics says that you do
the same thing but with matrices
uh and it happens to be complex matrices
but this isn't really a big deal if it's
just reals with negative numbers you get
uh most pretty much the same phenomena
it's just
mathematically a little nastier so
instead of probability distributions we
have uh what are called density matrices
they're also called states
and what these are n by n hermitian
matrices
they're positive semi-definite that
correspond this analogous to the
probability distributions being
non-negative and their trace is one
and we can also use call this the one
nor meaning the shatten one norm
which is equivalent to the l1 norm of
the singular values also called the
nuclear norm
has a lot of names so these are the
basic states they're
instead of vectors they're matrices uh
and of course their their spectrum is a
probability distribution
but then there's this additional degree
of freedom which is the eigen basis
and if you've heard that in quantum
computing the basic states are
complex unit vectors that's in the
setting where
these that's the special case of pure
states which are rank one density
matrices
and that's when you know the state
exactly and this is sort of you could
think of it as a common generalization
of probability theory
and pure quantum mechanics so it's when
you don't know exactly what the quantum
state is
okay so those are the basic states of
the theory what are the measurements
so by analogy it's natural that these
should be things with
uh all their eigenvalues between 0 and
1.
so it should be a positive semi-definite
matrix because it should always produce
a positive probability of accepting and
it should be upper bounded by identity
because the probability of accepting
should be never more than one
and so you naturally get these
constraints on the measurement operator
so hermitian
and all the eigenvalues are between zero
and one uh
again the probability of accepting is is
given by this
this inner product again the uh distance
between states is sort of naturally done
in the in the shattered one door okay so
these are
the axioms of of of quantum mechanics
and they're
basically just take the vectors and make
them into matrices take the l1
norms and make them into shatten one
norms uh
question how do you sort of interpret
this distance between matrices
uh the distance is the best bias
possible for any measurement
so if i know that i'm given
let's say quantum state row probability
half and quantum state sigma with
probability one half
and i get to divide whatever measurement
i like and i want to
guess which one i have with the best
probability of success
uh then the the bias that i that i'm
able to achieve
towards the the correct one is given by
by this quantity because the infinity
and the one normal dual
yes right basically the same argument as
in the as in the
classical case variation on the logo
that's right you can also call it total
variation distance this is sometimes
called the trace distance
or the total variation distance uh same
name as sometimes
okay um good so that's one system
now you've mastered one quantum system
now let's let's do two
quantum systems or two probability uh
probability distribution over two
objects
um so let's let's start with probability
because it's more familiar
if you have two independent probability
distributions
then the rule for combining them is
called the tensor product
so let's say i have uh
i roll one die and the distribution for
the value of it is given by the
distribution p and then i roll another
biased die and the distribution is given
by q
what is the joint distribution for the
two dice uh well the probability of
getting outcomes i
j is p i times q j so the vector
uh let's say that each die has six sides
the total is 36
then i have a 36 dimensional vector
whose entries are given by these
products
what is that vector it's the tensor
product so the tensor product is just
the vector you get by
taking all possible products between the
individual vectors
now i have this joint distribution
suppose i want to just observe
one of the two variables so what do
measurements look like so suppose i have
this joint distribution and i have some
measurement some decision rule about
just the first variable or just the
second variable then what the rule is
that i
tensor the measurement with a column of
the all ones column so it would say
you know i'm going to accept if i roll a
3 with the first out and i don't care
what the second one is
i'll take the appropriate m for the
first one and just tense it with all
ones for the second position
or if i want to make a to make a
decision rule based only on the second
one then i would do
all one's tensor m um
so this operation taking m and tensoring
on the all ones vector
you can think of that as a linear map
and its
adjoint is what the is the linear map
that takes a joint distribution
and goes to the marginals so if i
i have the distribution of of two
objects and i want to get just the
marginal distribution of one or the
other what i do is i
sum over all the values the other one
can take so the marginal for the first
position is given by summing over
the second position and the marshmallow
for the second position is given by
something over the first one
uh let me leave aside this last this
last row for now so what are the quantum
analogs
very similar so if we have a product
state we have one
quantum system prepared in one lab that
has density matrix row another one
in another lab with density matrix sigma
then the joint state
is just a big density matrix and here
the
rows are indexed by i j and the columns
are indexed by kl
and you just take the matrix tensor
product so it's a big matrix whose
entries are all the products of the
individual matrices
okay just directly analysis uh
measurement similar story if i want to
measure just the first one
then i mathematically do that by taking
the measurement operator for the first
one
tensored with identity for the second
system or vice versa if i want to
measure just the second one
again this is a linear map again the
adjoint of it
tells me the operation to get a marginal
so if i have a joint state and i'll
figure out
what is the marginal uh then there's an
operation that does this
it's called partial trace um
and uh what it looks like is i have this
this big
n squared by n squared matrix i want to
extract the n by n
state of the first system so the ij
entry of this
is given by basically taking the trace
over the second position so the traces
you sum over the diagonal
and here you can see we're doing it's
like a trace just over
over the second position this one is
doing a trace just over the first
position
so you say you can say that you're
tracing out a system and then what
you're left with is the marginal of
the marginal state of what's left
and uh directly analogous
one thing that's not analogous is
what happens so we know the product
states that sort of a direct analogy
and now what if you want to look at
things that are convex combinations
of product states so uh mixtures of
product states
for probability distribution so the
convex hall of p times or q
for probability distributions this is
everything you know every single
probability distribution
can be written as a mixture of some
probability distribution on the first
system
tensor distribution on the second system
you could just take them to be kind of
singleton distributions
another way of saying it is if um i have
some correlated information
with boaz uh it could be that there's an
external variable
that completely describes our
correlation if you knew that external
let's say pablo knows that external
variable then conditioned on that you
know we could completely determine
uh our our respective states and
condition on that we'd have no
correlation
that's always possible with classical
distributions because
pablo could just know everything right
he could just completely know our
variables
he doesn't uh but quantumly pablo cannot
know everything
um so it's not possible
uh another way of saying that is if you
take the convex
i'm sorry this p here should be a row
they look kind of similar
if you take the convex hull of all row
tensor sigma
meaning all convex combinations of state
for the
first system tensor state for the second
system you do not get all possible
density matrices uh
you get a set called the set of
separable density matrices
meaning ones where all the correlations
can be explained classically
and the things that are not separable
are called entangled and that's part of
what makes quantum theory interesting is
that the the the existence of entangled
states if you didn't have these
then quantum theory might be a theory
just of of individual particles
but then sort of on a macro scale things
would just be able to use classical
information
but this talks about how information
scales of the number of systems and so
it's
uh it means it has
fairly profound consequences um so
the set of all n squared dimensional
density matrices is
is bigger than the convex hull of of
products which we call the separable
states and this uh the things that are
not separable we call we call them
tangled
so uh okay so that was a lot of
definitions
uh let me tell you now one of the
problems that that arises from this one
of the computational questions
that we'd like to solve um and uh
it relates to an optimization problem
related to entanglement so
one other definition of of separable
i said you can decompose into density
matrices of course these
density matrices you could further
decompose into rank 1 objects so you
could always
any separable state you could also say
you can write it in in this form
and this way is nice because these are
the extreme points of the set of density
matrices
so here the pi is a probability
distribution and these v's and w's are
unit vectors
so you could say that um
the convex hull of vv star tensor ww
star
so you have this set and one
thing you'd like to do with it is
suppose you've
prepared two ions in your lab after
painstaking effort you've completely
mapped out the density matrix you've
prepared
and then you'd like to publish your
paper saying that you've created
entanglement
well is the density matrix youth
prepared actually entangled or not
so just the most basic question for a
convict set is weak
membership given a density matrix row uh
and it's weak membership because i don't
want to deal with right on the boundary
so i'll give i'll have the promise that
either
strictly inside the set or it's at least
epsilon far away from the set in some
norm
determine which of these is the case um
so this is sort of a basic computational
problem that we might want to solve
um and via kind of standard arguments
it's
roughly equivalent to an optimization
problem which is to
optimize some linear function over this
set and uh
linear functions and density matrices
nice to think of them as measurements
so although you don't have to so let's
say you have some measurement
m and you want to maximize the
probability that this is accepted
over all uh separable density matrices
rho
and this function is called h sap of m
meaning
h is like for the support function of
the set s
okay so this is a basic computational
problem
uh what can we say about its complexity
is it sort of some obscure
thing only interesting in some quantum
experiments or does it connect to other
problems
um and in fact it turns out to connect
to an enormous number of other problems
it's it's equivalent to uh many of the
other problems many of which you've
you've heard about earlier this week
so it's equivalent to um what i'm
calling the injective tensor norm
also called the tensor special norm um
probably the other names i'm forgetting
which is you have a tensor and you want
the maximum inner product
over all unit vectors x y and z
okay it's like a tensor generalization
of the the spectral uh sorry the largest
singular value
it's also equivalent to computing the
two to four norm of a matrix meaning the
largest four norm of the output divided
by uh the true norm of the input and you
heard about this
earlier in the week it's equivalent to
maximizing the two to operator norm so
instead of two to four it's two it
matches
vectors and the input is in two norm two
matrices and then the uh
norm of the output you measure in the
operator norm of those matrices
it's equivalent to maximizing degree
four polynomials over the unit sphere
uh and even to constant degree
polynomials and all these equivalents
all these equivalences are
there's no dimension factors when you
have if you have an epsilon error
it translates into an epsilon prime
error in the other problem with no
dimension factor
uh so they're really pretty sharp uh
pretty sharp equivalences
there's even a relation to higher degree
polynomials but then it's sort of the
equivalence is not in both directions
okay so it's this is sort of the angle
of this problem i want to focus on
but it's really the tip of an iceberg of
a very large number of polynomial
optimization problems
and part of why i'm focusing on it from
this quantum perspective apart from
because that's how i learned about the
problem
is that quantum gives you sort of a
natural normalization to it and
sometimes you can say things naturally
about it
but it's possible that for other
problems like small set expansion
there's a totally different
normalization that's natural and
figuring that out maybe part of how we
make progress in
in this area okay so so it's equivalent
to a bunch of things
um but is it is it hard maybe these are
all easy to solve
um so what do we know about this we know
um
if you want to get a constant error and
now this is constant
in the operator norm so the operator
norm might be much
larger than h so remember that h sep
is the maximum trace of m times any
separable row
the operator norm if its permission is
and psd it's the largest eigenvalue
so that's the maximum of trace m row
just for any density matrix
row so it's it's trivially greater than
equal to h sep
so this is kind of weaker than a
multiplicative approximation it's one of
the weakest
approximations i can think of for this
um
and even this fairly weak problem does
not appear to be in polynomial time it's
at least as hard as planted clique
and at least as hard as solving a
three-set instance
of length log squared n so if you think
three-set takes exponential time uh then
you think it probably takes time and the
law again to solve this problem
um so that's sort of the weakest um the
weakest version
uh what about multiplicative error so if
you could do a better approximation
and you need pretty weak multiplicative
error like you don't even have to get
plus or minus one percent you could get
it to within a factor of a hundred
and if you could do that you could solve
a small set expansion
uh which is an interesting problem
connects to unique games a lot of other
optimization pumps
so it would be very interesting if we
could do this uh
and this gives us uh another route to it
to proving hardness or
or or perhaps algorithms um
and finally what if you demand very high
accuracy so
let's say you demand additive error of
one over polynomial n
and i put operator norm here but i could
have put h sep because these
differ by at most a polynomial and n
factor uh so this could have been
i could have said this was
multiplicative error not sure why i
didn't uh
if you do this um oh i remember i did
if you do this then this is at least as
hard as three sets and now your input is
size n
so this is you know it's as hard as a
three-step problem of roughly the same
size uh and this is originally due to
gerbits and the
the best dimension of this polynomial is
due to lagal
nakagawa and shimura and they got this
to be basically
n poly log n this this thing in the
denominator so
which there's some evidence that might
be sharp as well so
uh this is sort of the range of hardness
if you want to get it to constant error
aaron you mean for the operator norm for
the operator norm that bond the thing in
the denominator is like m
and that's right that's right that's why
and that's why i didn't make it
multiplicative there yeah because i know
how to report the result
for multiple good uh okay so that's what
we know about about hardness
um and so
kind of one
i i'm not gonna really get into the
techniques involved here because
um they're they're taking a lot of
different directions
i will say that one nice thing that you
get out of this
um you know sort of a common question is
when do we need quantum questions to
quantum techniques to analyze things
that are not apparently quantum
and maybe you don't need them but sort
of helpful to look at it that way
so one thing that from these results
we know how to prove and i do not know
a nice way of explaining it that does
not involve
some quantum-ish things is this
two-to-four norm which is sort of
closely related but not quite equivalent
to smaller set expansion
we know it's quasi-polynomial hard so
this ends the log n hard
to approximate the two to four norm and
that's something which is uh
came from using quantum techniques and
and still uh
i don't know a simple way of explaining
it that doesn't involve some uh
something quantum
but i think that's maybe a question
because
to simplify the proof in any case okay
so
um okay so this is
kind of one problem which is a a basic
optimization problem that comes from
quantum information
and i want to switch gears and tell you
about a a different problem and to do
that first i'll give you kind of more of
the basics of quantum information
so i told you about one quantum state
and i tell you about two
uh now what about uh n quantum states
and
uh i'm sort of changing the terminology
a little bit
each individual system will now have d
dimensions think of d is small like
two uh and there's n of them
so there is a typo here
yes yes that should be n d
dimensional systems thanks um
and d dimensional systems have d to the
n dimensions uh
and the fact that the number of
dimensions grows exponentially with the
number of systems
uh is a basic and interesting feature of
quantum mechanics
it explains the power of quantum
computers you know why they
cannot be there's no obvious way to
simulate them classically there might be
a very non-obvious way but
if you try to just write down the state
of quantum computer it's very hard
uh and it also explains the difficulty
of classically simulating quantum
mechanics if i have
n atoms and i want to simulate their
joint state the naive simulation takes
effort
exponential and n and it was in fact
this realization that led feynman
proposed
using a quantum computer to perform the
simulation instead
and then kind of once you've accepted
that quantum computers might do better
on one problem
stimulating quantum mechanics then it's
sort of more plausible to believe they
could do better on other problems as
well
can i just add that yeah you know the
dice example if i have
n dice also has exponential dimension in
your formulation
but it's the separability that lets you
you know simulate things classically i
think people sort of cross over this
right so you get you can also get an
exponential speed up by going to
randomize things so if you have a
randomized algorithm
it's not known to simulate a separable
quantum computer right
uh there is that's a complicated
question uh if you if all the dynamics
are separability preserving then yes but
uh you could have it's uh but it's it's
not known
if you just are simply given the promise
that your quantum state is always
separable then it's not known how to
simulate it
but but if the gates are always
preserving separability then you can
simulate and if you start with a
separate
product state yeah there's also some
results that relate like the amount of
entanglement
like if i cut somewhere in my circuit
and i look how many qubits are entangled
then there's some relation between this
number of qubits and the similar
abilities
um yeah no it's true though that
this is sort of an exponential speed up
but we it's reminiscent of the earlier
exponential speed up
that we found when we went from
deterministic to randomized
because with a markov chain you've got a
little random index
pointing into a giant space uh and
you're effectively manipulating these
exponential size probability vectors but
you're not storing the whole probability
vector you're just storing a sample
so it's reminiscent of that but the
things you can do with a quantum
superposition
are more interesting than the things you
can do with a random sample
uh so i'm not gonna yeah i'm not gonna
talk too much about algorithms but more
about the optimization problems that
come with it i'll mention
there's another way of thinking about um
about these multipartite states
that maybe connects it to other other
things that you might be more familiar
with
um so the density matrix here
has has two n indices it has n
row indices each one going from one
through d and
n column indices each going from one
through d so you can think of this as a
2n
index tensor of which n of them are
labeled
as uh row indices and n of them are
labeled as column indices
so here i've taken the example of n
equals three um
and this is what rho might look like and
then many
operations you want to do can you can
interpret
as uh gluing these tensors together so
for example the partial trace
is you sum over you set i3 equal to j3
and you sum over all those values
and that just means basically drawing a
line between them
whenever you contract when you draw a
line then you sum over all the values of
that index
and if you want to perform a measurement
then you uh
multiply the two which means stick the
two next to each other
and then take the trace over the whole
thing and these pictures are nice
for example it's uh transparent from
here that trace
m row is equal to trace of row m uh and
there are a lot of
other things you can do with these
tensors
natural thing of multiplying two
states is there some natural
interpretation of that
um there is
it's yeah so there's one thing you can
do if you're a given
um let's take let's talk probability
distributions
so if i'm given a sample from p and a
sample from q
i can ask are they equal to each other
and the probability that they are will
be the inner product of p
and q uh similarly if i'm given two
quantum states
there's something i can do called a swap
test and the probability of it accepting
will be uh not quite but close to
trace rho times sigma so there's an
operational thing you can do that will
produce that yeah
um and
actually that swap test is used in some
of those hardness results like the
the two to four on thing okay so uh
good so what do we do with these these
big tensors um
i've talked about state what about about
measurements so one thing we can do is
we can measure a subset of the positions
um and i want to talk about something
that's related to a
physically you wouldn't call it a
measurement you call it an observable uh
which is something called a specifically
something called a hamiltonian
which is a way of describing the energy
of a system
uh so um in general if i have if i have
n
particles let's say i have n electrons
the energy
of this collection of n electrons will
be the sum of all the pairwise
contributions so electrons interact
two at a time and the energy is related
to the distance between these two
electrons
and so to get the energy for all n it's
not an arbitrarily complicated function
it's just a sum of all of the pairwise
properties of
some function uh over all uh sorry i sum
over all pairs of electrons
and evaluate some function of their of
their individual properties
and so the way to express this in matrix
form
is you talk about is it as a k local
operator
so a remember that if you want to ignore
position you want to measure one thing
and ignore another position
you put an identity in all the positions
that you want to ignore
and so if you have n positions and you
want to ignore all but k of them
you put identity in all but k positions
and the resulting matrices are called k
local or really any linear combination
of things like this are called
are called k level um
and one way to get intuition for these
means is think about the case when it's
diagonal and you're sort of back in
in the classical setting and this is
like
looking at a k constraint satisfaction
problem so how many things are satisfied
in a kcsp well it's some function of
subsets of the most k variables
in the boolean case this is like degree
k polynomials
over the hypercube so in the diagonal
case it's something that you should be
familiar with
and this is sort of the natural matrix
generalization of that
and they're also physically relevant
because the energy of physical systems
is uh always expressed in this form
specifically if the
there's some h and the energies of the
form trace h
times rho uh so this
raises the local hamiltonian problem so
given some
h which is k local and even though it's
a giant matrix
because there's not that many k local
operators this is a small dimensional
vector space you can ex you can give a
succinct description of h
so this is you can write down a short
description of h
the local hamiltonian problem asked to
find the smallest eigenvalue of h
i guess in optimization you often want
to find the largest eigenvalue
uh but here you want to find the lowest
one basically the same problem
but that's because physical states when
they're very cold likes to be in their
lowest possible energy configuration
but basically just find the smallest
eigenvalue
um of this giant implicitly specified
matrix
um okay so what can we say about this
problem
uh well we know from the diagonal case
that it at least includes
np because it's like max csp
and in fact it's a little bit harder
than np it's something called
quantum merlin arthur if you want to get
this one over poly accuracy
and this corresponds to uh
something that a quantum polytime
circuit can verify
if given a a quantum witness i mean a
witness that's a quantum state
classically we know a pcp theorem which
says that
uh even to get this to sort of constant
error is still
np hard quantumly we know that it's it's
np
hard but we don't know that it's qma
hard and there's something called the
quantum pcp conjecture
uh which uh says that this is qma heart
uh which i'm not going to go further
into but i just want to tell you kind of
the range of knowledge on this subject
you might ask sort of who would care qma
vs np
both sound really hard to me um and
one way i like to think about it is
what would it mean if the local if
there's if the local hamiltonian problem
was not an np but it was in qma then
that would mean
you have a hamiltonian you can
succinctly describe it
but then to show that the lowest energy
state
is below some value you cannot explain
that
with a classical witness the only way to
demonstrate
that the energy is below some threshold
is to physically give the quantum state
so it's like we make we finally make
contact with aliens the first question
we ask them is
uh look i can't solve the hamiltonian
problem of the proton
can you can you tell me how to solve the
quantum chromodynamics here
and they say and they say yes i have a
proof that the ground
state energy of this is such and such uh
and the proof is you know here's a
proton in the ground state
measure it you know that's not very
insightful
as a theoretical physicist you know your
goal is to
to give a theory that you can publish in
a journal hopefully they'll be
classical and copied many times and uh
yes np complete things are maybe very
hard to do but you are very
overconfident so you believe you can
guess the witness
uh but if it doesn't even exist then
there's there's no way to do that
uh so yes that's why people might care
about this
um and you know people talk about this
stuff often kind of abstractly and
they say like uh this is like a
quantum generalization satisfaction i
want to kind of emphasize
that this is really like solving
practical
examples of this is actually something
that's very important so let me just
give you a very
concrete example something called the
kagome anti-ferromagnet
so there's this uh mineral called
herbert smithite
we'll give you one guess as to who
discovered it
and it separate has these sort of
well-separated planes
and in each plane if you were to take an
electron microscope you would see some
image like this
but this is actually just a blurry
picture of a wicker basket
but it has similar structure
and you can see it just sort of uh
it's good for rosh hashanah actually
it's sort of a
pentagon this hexagon kind of kind of
pattern
um and there's a spin at every site and
they're anti-ferromagnetic which means
that
spins next to each other want to be
anti-aligned
and there's this uh belief that this is
something called a quantum
spin liquid which means it's neither
ferromagnetic nor para or diamagnetic
but it's this other
phase which has this topological order
something that
would be very interesting if we could
understand it better experiments are
suggestive
but we know exactly the hamiltonian
but we're just not smart enough to solve
it so we cannot write down an exact
solution
so what can you do one thing you can do
is numerics so
uh here's a paper that was a there was a
big splash it was published in science a
few years ago
by some major people and i don't know if
you can read this but we
simulate this model numerically on
cylinders with circumferences
up to 12 lattice spacings right and
this was huge like to be able to do this
on something of circumference 12
was like a great numerical result and
something that people were very
interested in
and uh you know and be able to push this
further and to improve the quality of
the evidence
would be would be like really a great
thing so even though asymptotically
these things are exponential
if you can kind of fight the exponential
in any way then that
can be of of tremendous interest um
okay so that's kind of an example of one
of the things you'd want to solve here
there are many other examples from from
chemistry
um and let me let me come back to theory
land and and talk about another way of
viewing the problem
so um i changed from k local to l local
uh so suppose you have an l local
hamiltonian and you want to find the
the the lowest energy then
um uh
there's another way of thinking about it
you can write h as a sum over these
local terms so
h sub s s is some subset of size l
h sub s acts only on that subset and
that means that when you take trace of
rho times h sub s that won't depend on
all of rho
that just depends on the marginal of row
on those particular sites
so let's call that marginal row
superscript s
so the energy of the system is this sum
of the energies of each little marginal
of rho
with the appropriate hamiltonian um
and so this is nice because
here the basic operators are huge
they're d to the n dimensional
and here the basic operators are not so
big think of l as like two
then these would just be d squared
dimensional matrices maybe d is two also
and then they're just four by four
so it's really a much much easier
problem uh or at least that
the objects involved are much smaller so
this suggests uh
a um oh there's gonna be a lot of d
and n this should be d to the l
dimensional
um sorry this should be d to the l
dimensional convex optimization
oh no no no no no i take that back it
and n to the l is right
it's like n because they're n choose l
different sites
um i psych myself out so
the this suggests a convex optimization
of much
smaller dimensions so before i said
there's an exponentially large matrix
find the smallest eigenvalue now there's
a bunch of small matrices there's
n shoes l matrices each of dimension d
to the l
and what you want to do is optimize this
linear function over them
but the catch is that the constraint is
killer
the constraint is that these local
density matrices
have to be globally compatible there has
to be an extension of them to a global
density matrix
and already for probability
distributions this is hard right you do
the same thing for probability
distributions
and if you could solve this quickly you
could solve np complete problems
and the catch there is that the
probability compatibility problem is is
hard
and uh same thing here this pro this is
qma can complete to check
so it's not uh you know it's not a
get-rich-quick scheme
but it does suggest a method of
approximating it
uh so here's a relaxation um
so you optimize the same linear function
but now
take a larger set of variables take your
variables to be
all subsets of at most k systems where k
is something larger than l
and demand that these when they overlap
be locally compatible
and this gives you a
as you increase k you get a more and
more accurate approximation when k is
n you're just you're solving exactly um
and this gives you a a hierarchy of
semi-definite programs for for solving
this problem
um and uh i'll i'll come back to this
soon and we'll talk about a slightly
more sophisticated version of this
um but i um yeah i want to mention for
now this this other perspective on the
problem
um so i'm going to return to local
hamiltonians
i first want to mention uh just to kind
of give you an
overview of the field a few other
variants of this problem that are also
interesting um
so one of them sorry the color came up
funny
uh is to find not just the ground state
energy because
you know that might be just some number
whether you learn just from one number
what you really want to know are
properties of the ground state so for
example
in the kagame antiferro magnet the
question is whether it's a quantum spin
liquid
which relates to correlation functions
between
spins that are far away you want to know
how does the correlation function behave
with distance
this is a local observable and so what
you want to do is
given the ground state estimate some
local trace of some local observable
with it
and that is nice because it you can
reduce it to
the same basic uh minimization problem
another problem which is somewhat harder
is to estimate the partition function so
the partition function of a quantum
state
is trace of e to the minus h
divided by temperature which i left off
because it's just a constant
uh and then sometimes you can take the
log of it you get the free energy you
take the derivative of that you get
all kinds of other thermodynamic
quantities and this is another
uh important thing that you'd like to
estimate and here the complexity is
somewhat different it's often it's pp
complete to get it
sorry i don't know i said that sharp
it's sharpie complete to do it exactly
uh but there are some special cases that
can be uh sometimes much easier
um like valiance match gates are an
example where you can you can do things
much better
uh finally another thing you can do with
these big hamiltonians
e to the minus h corresponds to uh
thermal states non-zero temperature e to
the i times
h corresponds to time evolution so if
you want to simulate what a quantum
computer does
it boils down to estimating matrix
elements of this operator
um and it's a bqp
complete to do this which means it's as
hard as doing a polytime
uh quantum circuit so these are kind of
all
different things that you'd like to do
with hamiltonians and uh
there's there's a lot of room for for
approximations of these different
problems so i just want to put them out
there as
uh things that would be very interesting
to make progress on using using convex
optimization
okay so uh i've mostly talked about
problems let me talk about
about solutions about how we can solve
them using things like the sum of
squares hierarchies that you've heard
about before
and first i'll give you a little
overview and then maybe go into a little
more detail
so one thing we'd like to do is
approximate the set of separable states
uh and there's a relaxation called k
extendable plus ppt uh pvt means
positive partial transpose um
and i'll say a little bit more about
this in in a minute
um so that's the first problem i
mentioned with separability testing and
there's a
an sos hierarchy for this another
problem
is uh the ground state energy this
lowest eigenvalue
and here there's a different observer a
different relaxation which i'll
also give you more details about in a
minute
which appears to be incomparable um it
seems like maybe they should be related
but i don't see any direct relation
uh there's a third one and i think i'm
i'm going slower than i thought so i
won't go into detail but i want to say
that the talk right after lunch by uh
miguel nevaz we'll go into more detail
about this one
and this last type of hierarchy uh is
also related to quantum problems
something called quantum games which are
related to interactive proofs
and it involves not the normal positive
stelling shots used for the sos
hierarchy
but something called the non-commutative
positive stelling thoughts which is
uh something i understand much less well
and uh has it was harder
it's harder to prove things about it
like it like it's convergent and the two
first two relaxations they are not
special cases of like the sum of squares
for like they are they are uh
but what i don't know is you know if you
have a proof that this one converges
does that give you a nice proof that
this one does or vice versa they
they feel sort of problems right yeah so
let me see a little bit more about this
first one
in a little more detail so instead of
talking about
um about step let me talk about
um something called sep
sim r for real so let me take convict
combinations i'm gonna take just real
vectors
uh x x transpose tensor x x transpose
so if this were sap this would be like v
b star tensor
w w star but this is a restriction but
it's pretty minor
it's you can show that computationally
this is just as hard uh
but it makes the math simpler to write
down so
you can think of this is like degree
four this is like all the degree four
monomials
and the natural sos relaxation is to
consider all the degree k
monomials and to give some opinion about
what all their expectations should be
uh these are the pseudo expectations
that you heard about
from i guess john and maybe david and
maybe maybe other people too
and so the way it works is you
take sigma to be a density matrix of
dimension n to the k so you can think of
it as having
k systems each n-dimensional and you
demand that it be fully symmetric so
there's two n indices
um and if you permute sorry two k
indices and if you permute
them in any way you get back the same
thing uh
and then if you trace out all but two
systems what you're left with
is your approximation here um so what i
mean by
by fully symmetric i mean let's say here
are your tensor indices
so if there's any way you can think of
of rew
of you know twisting these around as
long as you still have kind of three
lines coming in here and then three
lines coming out there
it should give you back the same tensor
um
in particular you can rewire it in ways
that does not respect the matrix
structure you can mix rows and columns
that's what this partial transpose means
is to mix the rows and columns just
of one position so
this was introduced by uh pablo and his
co-authors over 10 years ago
and they show that it converges and some
other properties of it
there's other versions that use less
symmetry as well so if you want to
attack actually the separable problem
not this this sort of toy version here
you do something called k
extendable and ppt uh
the details are just are not that
interesting about the difference uh but
i just want to say that
um when you hear about kxnb and pbt
you should think about this toy problem
and that sort of reflects what's going
on
uh so this is a hierarchy that um
that that often performs pretty well and
in the minute i'll tell you more about
about what we know about its performance
um we also have hierarchies for the
the lowest eigenvalue so i presented one
which is
to look at all the marginal states and
to demand that they be compatible
but if you use sum of squares you can
actually it suggests
actually something a little bit stronger
so let me just remember
uh sorry we recall the exact
problem so the exact problem is that you
want these uh
partial these things called reduced
density matrices to be compatible
meaning that there is an extension
to a global density matrix that's hard
um
let me give an equivalent formulation
still hard to define some map
l which is meant to be
uh and l is a map from
k local operators to real numbers so
whenever you're given a k
local operator l will tell you its
opinion about
trace of that operator times rho and you
say that
l is valid if there if it corresponds to
an
actual state so for any operator x it's
k local
l of x should be equal to trace of rho
times x
so obviously that's hard to check uh
so just an equivalent way of saying this
this problem up here and now
we can do a relaxation we can say well
let's just demand that l
satisfy as many properties that we can
test with a small
sdp so again
we minimize the sum of l of all the
local terms in the hamiltonian
and now what do we know about l if it
came from a valid state
certainly normalization is that l of
identity should equal one
that part's easy but also it should have
this psd
condition so if x is k over two local
then x star x is k local
and so it's something that we have an
opinion about we can say what l of x
star
x is and this is a psd operator x star x
is psd
so l this should always be greater than
or equal to zero
uh so if l is valid this will certainly
be true
uh of course it's not the only condition
you know unless until you take k to be
like n to be n you won't get this to you
know this won't be a perfect test
um but it'll be it'll be some test it'll
be it'll be a relaxation
and you can check it efficiently using
semi-definite programming uh
it's basically a straightforward
application of the sum of squares method
um so with sum of squares we have these
two natural hierarchies
and i think it's a great problem to try
to
um to better understand how well they
perform
um and we know a little bit about how
well these perform
uh not as much as we could the bounds we
have are nowhere near the
the matching results from complexity
theory um and so i think that one of the
main open problems here is to try to
improve that
in either direction um so i've maybe
ten ish a little less than that minutes
left let me try and quickly tell you
um some
non-trivial things about how about
bounding the convergence of these things
so uh to do that
yeah so let me just say there's been a
lot of work on showing that these things
do well
using quantum information theory um and
using things like quantum conditional
mutual information
uh and a lot of really uh wonderful
techniques that i love
that i will not have time to tell you
about um but
i can tell you about a classical analog
that is hopefully more comprehensible
and that expresses many of the key ideas
so
let me tell you now a classic classical
analog and if you
uh were completely confused before
that's okay this is sort of a fresh
start
um let's consider the problem of
quadratic optimization over the simplex
you want to maximize q with some input
you want to maximize the inner product
of q with p tensor p
where p is the probability distribution
this is equivalent to looking at the
convex whole of all the p tensor ps
which is a convex set obviously and
computing the support function of that
now even though it's a convex set it's
not easy to do this optimization because
we don't know how to test membership
efficiently in the set
uh so this will be a hard problem in
fact if you take q to be the adjacency
matrix
of a um of some
undirected graph then this maximum is
exactly equal to
one minus one over the case number which
is kind of a
it's kind of a cool result usually these
things are not you don't have any
sharp equality like that but here you do
and that gives you really a sense of how
hard this thing is to compute
um okay so what's the relaxation
there's a relaxation which is a close
variant of sum of squares it's basically
sum of squares
light kind of throwing away some of the
constraints
the relaxation will be to take q to be a
symmetric
probability distribution also called an
exchangeable distribution so it's a
distribution over k
objects each with an alphabet of size n
and it's symmetric meaning if you
permute these objects you get that the
same distribution
uh we'll call that an extension of the
distribution and then we'll take
pi which we hope is close to p
tensor p will take pi to be the the
marginal on the first two positions of
this distribution
okay so we take this symmetric extension
and then we
look at the first two sorry we take the
symmetric distribution we look at the
first two positions of it
okay so why is this a good distribution
the idea
is uh you can think of it like
um well yeah let me i'll say that in a
minute
so why is this why is this good this was
proved actually um almost 35 years ago
that this works well
um and then pablo and his co-authors
gave a totally different perspective on
this with uh
some uh in some ways stronger results
and these showed that the distance of
what you get of pi
to the convex hull of p tensor p goes
like one over k
so uh that means if you want to get
error that so
and this distance is in the variational
distance so
that means if you want to get error that
goes like the largest entry of q divided
by k
the runtime is n to the order k
and why is this something we should
expect one way to think about this
is you can if q is symmetric that means
it's a combination of different types a
type
just means uh there's this many ones
this many twos there's many threes
etcetera
it's just you fix some type and you put
them in all different orders
and then the difference between pi and
what it should be
it's like the difference between drawing
two samples with replacement and two
samples without replacement
and you can show that if you're drawing
these from an urn of size k
then as k gets large these two
distributions get very close
that's basically the analysis of
diaconas and friedman and what pablo's
co-authors did
was like a sharper like looking at all
the extreme points and
uh doing some more some more exact
things
um so this
is a so what's happened here we took a
sum of squares hierarchy
and we used reasoning about probability
theory
in order to uh to show that it converges
um and
there's um
another example of this which is a
little bit more sophisticated but i'm
really running short on time so let me
just say it very quickly
so it's an algorithm for nash equilibria
um
which i just maybe won't define if you
don't know what it is already
um and a relaxation of nash equilibria
is a correlated equilibrium
which satisfies all the same linear
constraints and nash equilibrium is a
correlated equilibrium that's a product
distribution
so correlated equilibrium of an lp4 so
what you want to find nash
is an lp with this product constraint
which is non-linear
so the complexity is sort of
quasi-polynomial um but i will not get
into that
and uh there's what i want to present is
that you can
and previously there's an algorithm
which is also quasi polynomial that
involves
uh enumerating over over epsilon nets
what i want to present is one using
um again a sum of squares like algorithm
and the idea of the following you search
over distributions
uh over k plus one players there's one
alice and k bobs and it has
the linear constraints are that every
marginal of
alice and one of the bobs should be
correlate equilibrium
conditioned on any possible values for
the previous box
so the size of this is like n to the k
and the number of constraints is also on
that order
so it's a linear program running in this
time
and the what i like about this is that
there's this
slick information theory analysis which
really fits right here
so um what do we have to show so we know
whether we're getting correlated
equilibria we can just show it that
they're nearly product
and how do you show that something is
when you have two variables conditioned
on a third how do you show that they're
conditionally nearly a product
that's like saying that their
conditional mutual information is very
small
and if you use the chain rule of
conditional mutual information
then you can show this pretty directly
so the trick i learned from
uh prasad uh and i've used it like
if i didn't if i didn't know about this
trick i don't want to have had any
research output i think over the last
five years
uh used a lot so entropy of a is the
most log
m because that's the support of this of
a which is upper bound for the mutual
information
which you can write as this telescoping
sum of mutual information of a
with b1 plus mutual information of a
with b2
conditioned on b1 plus dot a dot mutual
information of a with bk condition on
everything that came before
so there's k terms here they add up to
log m
so one of them's got to be small so
there's some i
such that the conditional mutual
information is less than log m
over k and if you take k to be this
number then you get the
the conditional mutual information is
small um
and that means that the the things are
conditionally almost independent
uh which means that this hierarchy does
a good job
so i find that really cool that these
hierarchies which really feel like
they're about linear algebra and
polynomials and algebraic geometry
you know here's this like thing from
information theory that can help analyze
them
and for the quantum hierarchies there's
a
really analogous explanation for why
they converge which is really
not much more work and i don't have time
to present it uh
but it's uh if you understand this then
it's it's not much more to understand
the quantum ones
uh and what the quantum ones say is
you get some bounds which maybe you can
ask me about later
if you want because i don't want to eat
into your lunch um
and in one case they're not sharp but
they're
almost and then the other case we
actually do precisely match our hardness
result so we know that
in some for the case of many parties and
it is sharp
um we also building on a result of
actually three people in the audience um
can show that this
sos for the smallest eigenvalue for the
ground state energy
um that here we can show that this um
this hierarchy does a good job for
graphs with um
with low threshold rank um
uh meaning that they have a small number
of large eigenvalues
um and i kind of just want to tell you
that these results exist because i i
don't have time to tell you
uh why they work except to say that
they're based on
information theoretic type ideas um
so sorry just some questions yeah so
these ones for lambda mean
the relaxation that you're using doesn't
use ppt right
that's right that's right um
and and also these results for hsap they
don't use ppt
um we in general don't really know how
to make good use of it
there's some evidence that it may be
very helpful um
okay so uh maybe i'll just skip over the
fact that you can do these things with
epsilon nets
uh i will say this is like most of the
proof so it's pretty concise also um
you can generalize it to factorization
norms i'll skip that too
um i'll briefly mention that there are
many problems so this
uh maximizing quadratic function of the
simplex
approximate nash h something else called
free games which is like you have two
provers but you ask them uncorrelated
questions
uh for all these problems we now have
basically identical performance between
the best epsilon net algorithm
and the best sum of squares algorithm
that we analyzed using information
theory
uh in only this case the paper by
uh pablo and his co-authors is there
like an explicit correspondence between
these two methods
otherwise it's just sort of the
suspicious coincidence that they yield
the same thing
so um that's something i would really
like to understand better
is if there's some more general reason
why we should expect these things to
uh to yield the same results and i
apologize for the fact that i didn't
tell you anything about the epsilon nets
so from my talk you would have no way of
of guessing how this column goes
but asking about it later and i can i
can tell you in person it won't take
long
um yeah so let me conclude by by saying
that
um there are a lot of open questions so
we have some hardness for the two to
four arm quasi-polynomial hardness
and we don't quite get quasi-polynomial
hardness for small set expansion
but it feels in some ways like we're
close and uh it'd be very nice to be
able to get that
in general we have some quasi-polynomial
algorithms and some quasipolynomial
hardness
sometimes they match sometimes they
don't and getting them to match in more
cases would be really cool
um dynamics i think is another place
where these hierarchies could be used if
you want to
have stephanie mentioned that if the if
there's always low entanglement
then you can get a good simulation but
what if there is a noisy circuit
with uh some version of low entanglement
can you
can you sort of make use of the noise
like for example if you want to simulate
the d-wave machine can you do that with
a
low a few number of rounds of the
hierarchy uh
in general we'd like to know more
conditions under which it's easy to
simulate for example find the ground
state of hamiltonians
relate hierarchies and nets i just
mentioned and finally uh
for the information theoretical analysis
of nash equilibrium we use the classical
conditional mutual information
quantumly it's been hard to make
progress because it's so hard to talk
about the quantum conditional mutual
information it's in many ways a more
mysterious beast
so i think this is also something worthy
of of direct study
uh here are the papers that uh
that i've worked on which involve this
stuff and uh
thank you for your attention and tell
you time for lunch
can you go back to the slide on epson
it's
this one here yeah freaking yeah
is your construction in the quantum case
similar to the so the uh
the top first three the constructions
are all through the morris empirical
method right
where you you basically you're on the
simplex and then you generate it you
mean
you feel that the size of the epsilon
that scales the way you'd like it to
yeah you're saying all the epsilon nets
use empirical method yeah does the third
does this the one for hsf also use an
empirical method or is there a different
construction no it also uses empirical
methods so in some sense that is
information theoretic right
i mean you're you're you're yeah because
you could say for the epsilon net it's
like you need k
samples and then for this one you need k
rounds and so maybe these extra rounds
are behaving like more samples
i don't know i don't know but i was just
gonna throw that out yeah
that seems plausible
it's always the case that if you have an
epsilon net algorithm that it implies
that you all that's sos also right
oh i don't know how do you know
i mean if how do you prove them it's
actually
i don't know if you need to uh yeah i'm
not sure okay that's a great question
and we can talk later i can tell you
examples where i know how to get
better bound with the epsilon net and i
know how to get with the hierarchy so
then
you know being able to achieve that with
a hierarchy would be really cool
i just want to say that what i mean not
i guess the yeah in those cases are the
epsilon that's generated by that random
in this randomized way or in those cases
yeah they are
it's just like you use like a better
turn off bound you know like taking more
advantage of the structure
so maybe the hierarchy also works better
but you have to improve the analysis
and since our methods of analysis really
do look different that i don't see how
to
improve the analysis the same way so if
i'm confused i mean somehow in the
at least in the simplex case you have an
explicit
method so so so in these cases
yeah in all these cases the what if you
generate
your external net randomly then you're
actually proving this
i mean it's on no no we're not we're not
generating that plan that's randomly
always serious no no that in that's the
construction is an existence
using the randomized method yeah
like the constructions will look like
this they'll say look if i have an
average of a bunch of matrices
and i sample k of them then with
probability greater than zero i'm close
to the mean
therefore there exists a sparse
combination of them which is close to
the mean so if i enumerate over
all sparse combinations i'm going to
find it
so they typically take this you know
have this form